I am really really glad that I get to
chair this panel although the i get
there are kind of bookmark panels here
today what it was like then although
it's to this panel is both about what
was like then and what it's like now and
then later in the day we're going to
have what it's like now with perhaps
shall I say a different generation of
people but for me this is just really a
special panel because everybody on it we
all in two cases really directly in one
case indirectly go back way into the
cold war went into the cold war and I
saw I'm just a couple of things I have
to say that I knew of Tom Kent shortly
after his assignment to Moscow in 1976
because my husband or man was become
would become my husband was a refusenik
and he met Tom and Tom they hung out
together and and because he called the
associated press Bureau to tell Tom that
he had gotten his exit visa do you
remember the story no you don't know
this story you were on homely when he
finally got his visa and George krinsky
took the message and sent it out as a
news release and he was expelled from
the Soviet Union a week later I told the
carting that story yesterday me no not
you know Krinsky was expelled yes um
Jonathan actually we met here and in
fact Jonathan in the years when Tom had
already cut his teeth in Moscow was
assistant director of the Harriman
Institute that I noticed is not in your
directly in your bio but the notice
what's there who head of the TV project
I supposed it that's all true but um so
and although Rosen I didn't meet until
more recent
way I feel like we've had connections of
many sorts that had go back about that
far so I'm really glad that she's here
and I do want to add one thing to I hope
she doesn't mind to UM her bio which is
she is the only American I know who has
written a dissertation in Russian and
defended it in Russian at st. petersburg
state university and two years ago we
met for years it was a four years ago
okay I mean so I think that that really
should be prominently you know put in
there so on that note I think this is
going to be one of the most exciting
panels of the day and we're going to
change the order a bit for various
reasons partially chronological and Tom
Kent's going to go first okay thank you
Cathy it's a pleasure to to be here and
yesterday sessions were were great i was
here from the morning session and the
speakers did a very good job of of
explaining how the pervasive climate of
fear that existed in soviet times is not
there at least so much these days how
there's a whole generation now that does
not know anything about Soviet power yet
at the same time I guess we we have to
keep in mind that every country is to
some degree the product of its past and
the effect of 70 years of Soviet power
doesn't disappear overnight and doesn't
disappear even in a generation so in
talking today about the the Soviet press
of the the Cold War period and and
drawing some some connections to to the
Russian press of today I want to talk
about what what similarities there are
what the modern-day Russian press is
perhaps internalized a bit from the
Soviet period and what in Russian
journalism today is truly new and since
not everyone here is a hundred years old
I will recap briefly some of the aspects
of the of the Soviet press we're talking
about the ear
of provident is ness Tia not the
latter-day versions of those papers have
appeared from time to time but the but
the real problem is vesti of the back in
the day the six page eight page versions
of six page rate page additions that
those that those newspapers put out with
a little six digit glove elite
censorship code on the back indicating
that had been approved by the by the
official sensors the days of gusta la
radio 11 organization on government
organization that controlled all
broadcasting in the Soviet Union and of
course the official tasks news agency
that that linked all of the Soviets news
media and clearly there was a very tight
relationship between the Soviet regime
and the Soviet press Lennon himself
considered himself above all a
journalist that's what he said on his
identification kernels it said you know
sure not least is his profession and he
said in the great famous quote from
Lennon on the press he said that the
Soviet press is not only an agitator and
propagandist but a collective organizer
of the people the press was owned by the
government and the party and so-called
public organizations under party control
they completely controlled any access to
printing presses they even controlled
access to photocopying machines the
press at the time was was not a Fourth
Estate it was not an independent force
the essence of journalism was really
party most the degree to which
journalism operated in support of the
party advancing the party line and
changing society for the better they
hoped Soviets would mock the Western
press is a so-called depo of ideas as
they call it just a place where
different ideas of sort of us stuck here
and there without any particular
coherence and they felt that if the
Soviet press ever became similarly
uncontrolled that could easily lead to
public confusion anarchy and return
the capitalist system now none of this
had anything to do of course with as we
say covering the news fires disasters
riots medical crises involving Soviet
leaders all this passed without mention
in the Soviet press meaning that
reporters at the time had to had to
basically try to gather this information
themselves which is very difficult in in
a huge country now and then there would
be one of these rumors that Brezhnev had
died we would call up the Kremlin if one
of our some in our office had the
courage to do so we would call up the
Kremlin and ask for mr. Brezhnev's
office and and say you know we hear you
know there might be some kind of a
health issue is he okay and they would
say something like well with rumors like
that he'll live a hundred years which we
took to be confirmation that he was
alive P&I said you could do this nine to
five monday through friday you know if
the if the rumor broke on you know
saturday night there was really no way
to confirm anything like this now and
then if the if the if the press was
obligated to report something that was
really bad for example there was a case
once or a big airplane crashed with
about half the Soviet general staff on
it and they felt that there was some
need to say something then one paper
usually Pravda would have a little box
on its last page about a one inch box on
the back page headline process via event
and they would say well a plane had an
accident and carrying important members
of the military and there were
casualties and that was all the coverage
you would get and all of this was
reflected very much in Soviet newsrooms
of the time and I use a newsroom in in
the modern sense newsroom in the Soviet
sense was a long quarter with little
offices off to the weed side where where
journalists at their writing usually in
longhand
articles that we then be described by
secretaries and so forth there was no
sense of a modern newsroom with people
running around in phones ringing because
that all implies urgency and immediacy
and that was just not the theme of the
Soviet press basically the the Soviet
press was there to report on or create
good news the only fly in the ointment
was that unfortunately this press had to
serve not only to to organize and
agitate and propagandize the people but
it also had to form Ted function as a
form of esoteric communication with the
18 million members of the Communist
Party things being what they were in
Soviet times you couldn't give the 18
million members the Communist Party a
log on where they could go to an
internet site and get the real story
they had to get the real story somehow
out of the newspaper at the same time
that to the ordinary reader the
newspaper had to look like it was awful
of good news so this gave rise to a
whole school of diagonal writing that
the ordinary reader might not note but
the people who knew what to look for
wood and this included things like
Pravda editorials that would inevitably
start with a headline like you know
they're older it was spittin a blog on
auto de along the road of success for
the good of the people and it would say
you know livestock raising is really
great these days and we have all this
livestock and more and more and more
meat and more and then inevitably in the
middle of the editorial there would be a
paragraph that started at naka however
and it would say however not at every
farm as the livestock sheltered the way
it should be sometimes you know they're
leaks in the roof and so for that be one
paragraph and then the rest of the
editorial be how wonderful everything is
so the people you know whose job it was
to know the party livestock officials in
in
in far-flung regions would say okay
there's a campaign on to fix these barns
and will be better but otherwise you
know the casual reader you wouldn't know
same thing with whenever the party line
had to change and this is a problem
since in principle the party line should
never have to change because the
Communist Party was simply carrying out
in a historical inevitability so they
would know how history was developing
but now and then they had to change
policy and when they did this would be
introduced usually in the Soviet press
with khakis vesna as is known which is
usually for anything with total change
in in in in palisade as is known the
Soviet Union has always stood for
compromise with the United States on
certain questions of nuclear arms aha so
this was the Soviet announcement that
they were changing policy and going to
negotiate there is also a not
surprisingly a great obsession with
security the Soviet press scrubbed at
anything that might be moderately useful
to any any kind of foreign intelligence
agency or military organization such
that some of these productions became
really satires of themselves and my
favorite was always a radio program
called polio via porta or mail call it
was a program about Soviet soldiers
serving in different places and all the
things they were doing and it would say
for example you know vadim yvonne off
rights to his mother that he's having a
wonderful time and doing great things he
is carrying out important duties at a
certain location so there you go in
terms of expose as well there were
expose is sort of in soviet style a
typical example of an expose and the
press might be that that the shoe repair
kiosk outside the Kursk railway station
the glue isn't that good so if you get
your heels repaired and it rains the
heels could fall off well there you are
the press it work
and the other thing of course was very
important to to us correspondence at the
time was Lee chatter torneo gazeta which
came out every Wednesday where which
would give us each week sort of a
scandal on a silver platter like it's
it's hard it's hard for young people to
find places to meet or you know it's
hard to find a good husband these days
and we were so grateful and we lapped
this stuff up because it was the only
inside slight admission maybe everything
wasn't totally perfect as for
journalists themselves in the profession
there was a constant tug of war during
the Soviet period between professional
journalists and amateur journalists I
guess you'd say under Lenin and under
Stalin there was a great movement of
worker peasant correspondence sorta
Bochy associate kind of sponge into the
rub sell course as they were called and
these were sort of the amateurs with a
working from the idea and you hear this
now sometimes too and in modern
journalism that you know you don't need
professional journalists and anybody can
write about the experiences of their
life so wraps el-khoury were very
important after after after the crew
chef period starring alec say a jubei
the son-in-law of Khrushchev who was the
editor of his vest heeya they started to
put more emphasis on the
professionalization of the press and
making reporters feel they had a certain
professional responsibility to the truth
at least to some degree and that certain
professional skills were required and a
lot was done to try to raise the
prestige of the profession they even had
a journalist song you know prodigies me
journey of assume at a Pravda nigga see
Miss yet asahi blood not often assume
petanque of cherished ocean yet so
anyhow the idea being that you know out
of our out of our notebooks come the
truth that we conveyed the future
generations so today obviously a lot of
the Soviet era barriers to entry and
journalism have come down there is
anybody can start a newspaper pretty
much anybody can can start a blog other
other big changes there's you don't have
this this pervasive climate of security
at least that the but the press is
involved in we have to be other day in
in two thousand for example the the
Russian submarine the Kursk was lost at
the time the authorities were announcing
that the actually the crew was okay
oxygen was being pumped in but the press
was free enough to report the truth
which was oxygen was not being pumped in
and in fact the whole crew died during
the the terrorist event at the nore dust
theater performance that against the
square in new in in Moscow in two
thousand there was a lot of press
coverage of the of the movement of
security forces toward the theater in
order to in order to try to rescue the
hostages everyone acknowledged even the
press after that that perhaps
suppressant taken a little too much
liberty with reporting security
information that actually had been
useful perhaps to the to the hostage
takers so there's much more now in terms
of expose A's of serious things although
Alex assuming off of the glass Defense
Fund says that in Russia there's now
freedom of speech but nothing gets heard
in other words you're free to do expose
is in the paper but nothing necessarily
happens usually show you can show
malfeasance but but that the prosecutors
may not act at all but there remains a
nexus between politics and the press
some organs as we know are owned or
controlled by political groups and
oligarchs government and so forth and
the government still consider some
controls to be necessary and sometimes
they speak of this in fairly Soviet
language in november 2003 there's an
article in raza scag as yet by the
Italia cough who said freedom of speech
is not one of the top priorities of the
human race but just one of the
cornerstones of the can
temporary market democratic political
system he said freedom of the press and
pluralism of opinion can lead to the
disintegration of society and the state
freedom of the press is in fact freedom
of speech for journalists not all
citizens in a given society and freedom
of the press is in some sense a
restriction on freedom of speech for the
remaining citizens in a given society he
said the main television channels in
Russia are political nuclear weapons and
Russia's central political leadership
has made a decision to keep control over
political nuclear weapons these days of
course there can be publications and
blogs run by opposition groups and we
may be on the brink of seeing more of
them but the question is will they be
agitators and propagandists and
organizers against those in power or in
the tradition of the press being for
political purposes or simply reporters
of the news and it's not clear that
everyone simply wants the news to be
reported as it is the latest poll I've
seen is a row mere Paul in 2004 that
found that seventy-six percent of
Russians consider censorship to be
necessary Alex they seem went off of the
glasnost Defense Fund sense that a lot
of Russians seem to feel that it's
really peculiar for newspapers to do
expose ace if if the if the newspaper
discovers that someone is is embezzling
money a public official why wouldn't
they just go to the prosecutors and and
and tell the prosecutors as a prosecutor
will go to rest on the skies why why why
make a public spectacle of it why
embarrass everyone why why make a scene
it's like it's like when there's a fire
once in Moscow as taking photos of it
and woman came up to me and said of all
the beautiful buildings on this street
why are you taking a picture only of the
one that's on fire so there's a feeling
that did you know you want to maintain
some kind of dignity why do we have to
have a horrible stuff in front of us and
last year I was moderating a
on ethics at the russian state human
humanities Institute University in
Moscow and there were quite a number of
young russian journalism students we're
not talking about you know old old
sharks of Soviet journalism we're
talking about young russian so
journalism students who also felt that
censorship was appropriate there had
been shortly before a riot at the
managed in Moscow where where a lot of
well skinhead types more or less had had
attacked a lot of people from the
Caucasus sort of a ethnic riot and a
number of these young students said they
think that probably should not have been
in the press all it does is is make
things look bad and inspires people to
to to become violent themselves and it's
best kept quiet so I'm going to stop
there look forward to the discussion and
I promise not to sing again I like the
singing the singing was a high point but
of many wenches the dance video so I'm
gonna so I'm going to restoring in an
anecdote that in the summer of 71 on
nevsky prospekt it's love and I had
managed to find a taxi which was already
know strange and but there was this
enormous crowd in front of Kazansky
sabor and I'm going you know and it's
lovin the taxi driver going oh we better
go out and find out what happened and
I'm going now you can just read about it
in the news tomorrow I mean I was a
sophomore in college and he looked at me
like what planet did you fall from you
know but you know so also the you know
acceptance that there was going to be no
news in the press the next day and if
you wanted to find out you better find
out for yourself anyway I'm gonna pass
this on to Rose Brady who's going to
speak next okay thank you very much i
also want to thank the harriman
institute in the organizers for inviting
me to this conference I thought
yesterday was fascinating and I learned
a lot before I start I don't know if
anybody minds this but I was wondering
if I could just find out how many people
who are here today we're here yesterday
okay and how many people are so X Soviet
citizens okay just wondering some of my
comments will bear a slight resemblance
to what Ann Cooper said yesterday if you
were here for the first session because
we overlap but I had a very different
focus from her I had the privilege of
covering the end of the Cold War for the
US business economic magazine business
week now known as Bloomberg Businessweek
i arrived in Moscow in August 1989 and
status bureau chief until the summer of
nineteen ninety three but I've gone back
and forth the fair amount since then in
the second half of the 90s I was working
on a book on the Russian economy and as
Kathy mentioned in the 2000s I was
working on a dissertation for st.
petersburg state university in their
political science and international
journalism faculty and and my last time
was way back in 2009 to be in Moscow so
I'm not as up on the Russian current
Russian journalism but I hope people in
the audience can help us out because I
was asked to speak not only about my
experience covering the end of the Cold
War but also whether the Cold War's past
still influences media coverage in the
US and Russia today and finally to
comment a little bit on the challenging
challenges facing the media in both
countries today to prepare for this
presentation I decided to go back and
look at the diary I kept not every day
but from time to time while I was in the
Soviet Union which I haven't looked at
in 20 years and when I look back at it
what struck me is how uncertain and
confusing the whole unfolding story was
I'll just give you three examples as
early as September 1989 I wrote it is
hard to avoid the feeling that things
are unraveling here in the Soviet Union
considering the strikes the rise in
crime in the National nationalist unrest
of course a lot happened in nineteen
ninety but I'm going to skip forward to
91 on january twentieth nineteen
ninety-one I
wrote for the first time here and
perhaps for the first time in my life I
feel that I am living in the midst of
something evil that is about to take
place or is already taking place this
was after the events in the Baltics when
Soviet tanks and troops attack civilians
at the TV tower in Vilnius and killed 14
and of course it was still several
months before the coup which the August
1991 coup which helps speed the collapse
of the Soviet Union finally after the
three-day August coup the pace of events
was so quick that in September 4th 1991
I wrote I find it incredibly difficult
to analyze the political situation here
so yesterday we heard from steve cohen
and he had a lot of criticism for us
journalists and how we presented the the
soviet union yesterday he focused on
post 92 but he also didn't really like
the way journalists presented it before
that as far as i recall and i just
wanted to point out that people were
trying to figure it out and it wasn't
that easy we wrote about politics for
Business Week we wrote about the warming
us-soviet relations and the incredible
decision that has it seemed that
Gorbachev let Eastern Europe go its own
way i can remember I'm sure Jonathan
remembers this that grass him off the
Soviet foreign ministry spokesman at the
time called it the sinatra dr a you know
I did it my way I'm not going to sing
but and we wrote about the popular
demonstrations the first one that really
surprised me was in February 1990 it was
just before a central committee plenum
that did away with the monopoly on the
Communist Party's power or the Communist
Party's monopoly on power and about a
hundred thousand people took to the
streets I like to go to those demos both
the pro-democracy and the the
pro-communist demos and what always
surprised me is that people were willing
to talk to you and to even give their
names I mean even the ones that were
hanging holding up signs saying Yankee
go home and stuff
like that but even though we wrote about
politics the main focus for business
week was the economy the politics
provided the backdrop for Business Week
to the economic story and we looked at
the political story mainly through an
economic prism we focused on the fact
that Gorbachev was trying to shift
foreign and domestic policy in an effort
to strengthen the economy is the key to
security and this is weak framed the
economic story not all the time but
often as a reformed story what steps
were being taken to try to solve the
problems of the Soviet economy the
budget deficit the debt all the things
did anybody who looked at that period or
lived through that period remember the
really weak ruble the slow growth the
shortages all that stuff what opposition
did he face what did the people really
want it was a time of shortages as you
recall line strikes all of that stuff
and as the economy worsened we wrote
about and other people did too about how
the the in broadcast about how the
various Republic started to declare
economic sovereignty and refuse to send
their funds to the center as they always
had this was a precursor it turned out
of the declarations of independence that
would follow the coup this week also
wrote about the early experiments in
business back then companies were called
cooperatives it was a more ideologically
acceptable term but these cooperatives
faced constant bureaucratic hassles and
tried to do their business as did the
newly established Western Soviet joint
ventures which were the first such
ventures since about the 1920s that were
allowed and they fought that the
partners of these ventures often fought
over how to manage the company who owned
how much and all the like in fact a
major theme of business weeks coverage
was the battle for Soviet wealth to me
the battle for wealth was and is
intertwined with the battle for
our leaders of the Soviet military
complex back there fought very hard
against changes that might shrink their
factories and cut their privileges the
partners in the first us-soviet joint
venture that I was telling you about
they were combustion engineer
engineering a Connecticut company that
was later bought by the Swedish company
abb and a Moscow petrochemical refinery
these guys could not get along even
though sort of both Gorbachev and and
reagan signed off on their venture but
what was fun about that story is both
sides separately complete bitter too
bitterly to me on the record and I wrote
the whole thing out and after I
published it they both were very mad and
was very congratulation was fun you're
supposed to do uh soon off people you
deferred the first private businesses
the co-op's made money by exploit
exploiting distortions in the mark and
the centrally planned economy and there
were lots of distortions I'm not going
to go into details but we can talk about
it later but in 1990 Mikhail
Khodorkovsky who probably ever everybody
remembers later ended up going to jail
and is still there spoke to Businessweek
and that was fair that was fairly on
early on for him he had made his first
big money through his Komsomol
connections and the bank he founded with
his Komsomol colleagues men attempt and
he told me only in the Soviet Union can
you make money from air and that's sort
of how those guys made their first money
so as a Western correspondent in the
Soviet Union in the late early in the
late 80s and early 90s I found the big
challenge was trying to understand the
story behind the story how much
opposition really was there what was
realistically possible and as I said at
the beginning it was rather difficult to
figure out but the great news was that
people were willing to talk to you very
different from the experience that Tom
had obviously we read the press and
learned a lot from the press but we
didn't have to be quite as guessing and
what we were reading to understand what
was going on so economist
litical analyst deputies even leading
Communist Party officials were willing
to talk to a business magazine like
Business Week and it was easy to talk to
the entrepreneurs back there and the
foreign managers involved in joint
ventures and as I mentioned earlier
evening even ordinary people were
willing to tell their names so to
summarize those were great years to be
an economic correspondent in Moscow and
we learned from the press we talked a
little bit yesterday and will probably
hear this afternoon about the technology
that's coming today back then the bit
one of the big innovations was Interfax
which started delivering news on a very
timely basis via fax after I finally got
my facts but it it was it played an
important role in the coup so one thing
that I think is a big difference between
back then for journalists and now is
that I never felt any fear it's true
that I didn't cover the ethnic conflicts
in Azerbaijan and places like that
because Businessweek didn't think that
that was the story for our magazine the
only times I felt fear was during the
events in Lithuania which I witnessed in
which I scared scared me quite a bit and
at 4am the second night of the August
coup when I was standing underneath the
comic-con building which was next to the
white house which is made of glass and
they said a column of tanks was coming
and I thought what am I doing here but
in any case they never came so those
were the only two times I was afraid but
if you fast forward to today as we've
already discussed a little bit yesterday
and as I'm sure we'll hear more of today
today that reporting climate and Russia
is very dangerous for journalists
especially for hard-hitting journalists
we saw from the code from the Committee
to Protect Journalists yesterday more
about how the independent media
organizations are attacked harassed even
killed with impunity I wanted to clarify
one point that came up yesterday
check the website of the CPJ and
according to the CPJ website if i
counted the names right 13 journalists
were murdered between 1993 and nineteen
ninety nine and twenty have been
murdered since 2000 that's a that's a
pretty bad record for both periods to me
the harassment and attacks our
reflection of desire or maybe a
reflection at least of a desire of those
who are in power whether its political
power or financial power to resist
change maybe you could call it an echo
of the opposition to Gorbachev efforts
that change more than 20 years ago
obviously Russia is very different today
than the Soviet Union was 20 years ago
but as an observer from afar I can't
help but see certain echoes for example
the battle for Russia's wealth continues
witness the reports of vladimir putin's
friends enriching themselves possibly
thanks to their connections to the
president and involvement with
state-controlled companies such as gas
prom and Rosneft although of course the
president denies that the huge and I'd
love to hear what other people say about
that the huge demos that if the times
did a pretty good story a real good
story on that riesling the huge
demonstrations that have taken place in
Moscow in the last several months can't
help but remind me at least a little of
the demos of 1990 and i happen to have
been in china when putin was booed at
the end of november i was working with
the Chinese media apartment partner of
media business week and they were so
fascinated to hear what was going on in
Russia but the scene of Putin being
booed reminded me of the incidents in
their different of course but in the
incidence of in early 90 when
rank-and-file members of the Communist
Party started kicking out regional
leaders and two men's fared loss skin in
places like that so I admit these
comparisons may be superficial but to me
they say that maybe the strains of the
late soviet period remain relevant today
in Russia and as we discussed and we'll
discuss more as for us Soviet relations
there still are cold war type attitudes
I won't go at length but the pressure
that the like Matlock McFaul I mean d
that's a 14 Smith US ambassador Mike
McFaul has come under recently as a sign
of the old suspicion of America on the
American side this is sort of an
economic point but I find it really
surprising that the old jackson-vanik
amendment which was passed in nineteen
seventy-four to encourage the Soviet
Union to allow Jewish immigration to the
US still exists the amendment denies
permanent normal trade relations to
Russia and it's an anachronism and if
it's not repealed by this summer
actually the US will be penalized
because the summer Russia joins the
World Trade Organization and sanctions
can be made against the US if it doesn't
allow Russia to have the same trade
relations as as other nations in the
world trade organization that's a kind
of an obscure point but it's a
jackson-vanik is a symbolism that at
least some members of the US Congress
are able to kind of move forward I think
the issue right now is should something
else replace it to keep the pressure on
Putin on human rights and i think that's
that's probably a good thing but they
have to move on and figure out a
solution to that in spite of these
tensions between the u.s. and the saw
russia others you know are on syria and
iran i personally sino-russian
anti-russian Cold War fervor in the
American media if the US media report on
Russian policy towards Iran or
congressional attitudes towards
jackson-vanik or enlarged large demos
and in Moscow and other cities I just
think they're doing their jobs and
rather than the cold war itself I'd like
to argue that other forces and Lee
unleashed in the aftermath of the Cold
War have influenced the media landscape
war I'm not going to talk about this at
length we can talk about during the
discussion if you're interested but the
two most important our technology and
market economics and these go hand in
hand of course the internet blogs social
media etc have given audiences many more
opportunities to receive the news but
they've also created tremendous economic
pressures that's led to a crunch in
foreign reporting as bureaus have been
shrunk or cut back those who were here
yesterday saw a great presentation by
Fordham's Beth noble another former CBS
correspondent who talked about how the
American press corps in Russia has
really shrunk and actually foreign
bureaus around the world have really
been cut back at the same time the focus
of foreign coverage has changed since
the end of the Cold War naturally but
except for tumultuous moments Russia and
the ex-soviet Union is no longer
unfortunately a big story we've had the
ethnic conflicts in the 90s in
Yugoslavia and other countries we had
911 the terrorist attacks Iraq and
Afghanistan there was a very interesting
study done last year by the pew research
center's project for excellence and
journalism and they analyzed over 52,000
stories produced by US media TV etc
Radio Russia represented 0.4% of the
coverage just 0.4 percent Iran was one
percent Iraq was one-point-three percent
and Afghanistan was three-point-six
percent the most important story was the
US economy at thirteen point six percent
that shows you one Russia's small
compared to the other foreign stories
but also that Americans aren't
interested in that much outside their
own borders right now I'd be interested
to see a similar study for the Russian
media I haven't found it yet but maybe
somebody anecdotally can talk about how
how much the u.s. is covered right now
in the
Russian media I hope that other
panelists and the audience will weigh in
on on how much you think Cold War
attitudes remain in the Russian press I
would simply say that if Putin and his
administration espoused anti-american
cold war-style views and order up
articles from the Russian media for
money as Fordham's Beth Noble said
yesterday then the Cold War probably
still does have an influence on the
Russian media at least indirectly
through the Kremlin at the same time my
guess is that independent media and
journalists face technological and
financial challenges just as the media
in the u.s. does but probably much much
more so because of all the political
pressures that they face when they
report especially hard-hitting stories
this pressure can include financial
raids closures and so on and as we've
discussed the journalists face personal
risk so to try to answer the question
that I was posed it may be possible that
the Cold War legacy in the Russian press
is stronger at this particular stage
than its legacy in the US media but I'd
like to hear what other people think and
I'm I look forward to the discussion
thank you very much for your time and
attention we move on to Jonathan Sanders
knowing Jonathan and his sense of
showmanship and looking up at the screen
I would invite the other panelists and
myself to perhaps move to the audience
so we can see the whole one you're
moving let me say that I'm thrilled to
be here with wit Tom and rose when i
first started reporting from moscow in
1977 when I wasn't supposed to be
reporting the first story I did was the
death of that great American that hero
of American culture and intellectual
sophistication Elvis Presley and the
reason i knew i was doing a good job was
because some of the people that i went
out and interviewed sound a little bit
like the people tom was reporting
on and virtually everything I know about
the fall of the state system and the
rise of capitalism i know from roses
book i also want to say this is on the
record right there is a tension between
academics and journalists academics like
my friend steve cohen loved to point at
the deficiencies of journalists and how
bad the coverage has been beth noble who
i write with beth and i just wrote a
piece about demovsky i was helping her
prepare those statistics about the
decline in u.s. bureaus in moscow well
guess what when I was at the Harriman
Institute we had six historians of
Russia and the Soviet Union how many do
you have now where's the economic
downturn that's had an impact here it's
not just journalists Cold War which Cold
War that's what I want to know now I'm
I'm a confused academic so i only have
something from yesterday from yesterday
you know i'm very glad to see that they
got this new technology here obviously
they've taken the money that this
immoral president of Columbia University
was able to betray the trust of the
Harriman family sell our house and buy
this nice new equipment and I say bravo
to them which Cold War when Rose mention
Mike McFaul and I love that you got Mike
McFaul confuse
with Jack Matlock I only hope that my
team does as good a job as Jack what was
the first correspondent from Russia from
the United States and Russia I'll give
you a hint he's also when the first
American diplomats later John catalyst
and I would suggest to you that there
was a cold war than 18 11 that if you
read his letters and his wife's letters
back home the first correspondence
letters corresponding it is a lot like
light is facing out in Moscow what Cold
War this is two days ago in Saratov I'm
glad I have the president of the
International dusty upski society to
explain this to me which mall did
justice to say two plus two equals five
is also a good thing Oh nothing's
contained the cold war on the people of
the past huh okay yeah yeah I've been
doing this for a long time at the high
level at the grassroots level i showed
you basalt ski for a long time we kept
busy covering people like this what
would a discussion of covering the Cold
War be like without a pure Stalinist
denunciation pure denunciation let me
denounce to Jeff thank god is dead
people use this as an explanatory
framework for explaining Russia to
Americans it is garbage it is wrong it
gets you in trouble I think what we need
to do is take something simpler instead
of just relying on text we need to think
in pictures after all we know from
walter Lippmann that
dealing with foreign policy people
operate on pictures in their minds I
learned this room are chiral Stroman not
from some fantasy journalism school
thank God I never went to journalism
school this is the person I think we
should take as in our text for today
Margaret bourke-white Margaret
bourke-white was a multitasking
multi-tool journalist she took
photographs she shot one of the first
films about Russia she was the test of
the news is covering a crisis how did
the New York Times cover the 1917
revolution badly she covered for CBS
News the German invasion of Russia on
radio with her husband the famous
journalist well he was a writer really
first be called well first gets mother
said you write well honey but ya lousy
voice for radio look what she says
Russia was a late a lesson in patience
my experience as a correspondent and my
experience as a student of
Correspondence is that the keys to
successfully covering Russia and for
allowing your insights to filter back so
its coverage by Russian journalists of
Russia and the United States is patience
pictures and people the last big story I
did was the best one slaughter
sanctioned by mr. Putin in which 366
were killed 186 children how was I able
with the entire press corps of the world
there and the FSB to scoop them and get
the only tape shot inside the hostage
situation by the terrorists themselves I
pay not a penny more despite what you
hear in the Federal Assembly people who
like turning me down for visas things
that I Drive someone I did not accept
with my personality I spent six weeks
sitting outside the Hulk of the school
just talking to people and from one
person I had another person another
person and I just and the key to getting
things done in Russia always has been
your friends Lenin was right not is
plannin my Lennon you get by with a
little help from your friends Margaret
bourke-white went 1931 lovely pictures
this is called butterfly dance you'll
notice our great folk heroes Stalin and
went in there they're still there by the
way I think you are the police still has
are you the last time i was in
vladikavkaz in one day i managed to get
stopped and arrested by the police seven
times but please don't hassle you very
much her patients god heard this
photograph the Nazis attacking the
Kremlin wasn't this what the central
conflict of the 20th century was in
large measure about Cold War hot war she
was interested in looking at a colorful
machine we've got a very colorful
machine and machines called quarter
koffsky the machines called be lon
Margaret bourke-white went 1931 for
Fortune magazine a business publication
she took this picture recognizer who is
it Stalin's mother think of what she
gave us in the world anyone have an icon
omake does this was dis swimmable
time is our most precious possession
when your broadcast journalist time is
effervescent it's there it's gone it's
there it's gone but you have to wait for
this she made these two remarkable
movies that nobody has ever seen and she
came back but you came back that you
came back you have to stick with it if
there's a cold war you have tennis which
cold war what are the limits how are
things changing what don't we know
eventually through her friend Harry
Hopkins she got to take this picture
which guess one this is the only picture
where you see Stalin had bad skin ponch
marked you know do you know how much you
used to be able to get for a black
market copy of this in the Volga I got a
complete set of this DF steer that
CBS News opened its bureau in Moscow
with the German attack the bureau was
closed down due to budget considerations
and something called Stalinism real cold
war in the late 40s reopened in 55 with
this man Daniel Schorr
look at what Dan says a reflection on
the obsessive sense of secrecy and a
lack of self-confidence at one time MTV
was the freest one of the best news
organizations broadcasting in the world
we're in their coverage of the war in
Chechnya then CBS News had ever been in
their coverage of Vietnam Remember The
Smothers Brothers were pushed off the
air for their coverage of Vietnam yet a
lack of self-confidence a lack of a lack
of openness a desire for secrecy has
propelled mr. Putin my official friend
when I was on I Rex to do something
different ask Dan Shore kept asking
every week persistence patience and
people for an interview on Face the
Nation one hour these nations just now
going to an hour hour since the fifties
they got it out for nikita Sergei in 57
with the great deal of trepidation
because they were afraid of McCarthyism
and see being seen as a tool of the
Communists he went in and he interviewed
for an hour straight Khrushchev Gustav
refused to put on makeup said I'm not an
actor and it was pretty much it was a
sensation because it was an innovation
except for one line of text in the
interview when Dan Shore asked him about
relation different interpretations of a
Marxist doctrine about conflict in
society as applied to China and the
Chinese had a different answer to
conflict in Marxist terms than the than
the Russians Soviets Harrison soils
the great New York Times correspondent
who started out not being so great when
he was first in Russia picked up on it
and this was one of the big signals in
the American press 1957 that there was a
coming conflict with China and you
remember a conflict with China is what
Andre Amalric talks about in his
prophetic book will the Soviet Union
survive to 1984 the answer was no
another innovation on film not in not in
newspapers that you can read on
microfilm which is the preference of
academics and don't spend enough time
looking at popular culture visual
just an anecdote about how much they
ignore I started before him this morning
play goes up important on local I did
two pieces on that 152 minute film in
nineteen eighty with Samuel Rathlin that
was on PBS honey harbors program and I
get dan rather than do a 60 minutes
piece 12 minutes under sucks I always
thought that the subsidy was a great
feat of understanding not the dissident
culture but the unofficial culture the
corrosive culture be not obedient
culture the nonconformist culture that
went across social groups across classes
across across the Soviet Union and I
also thought that when rock'n'roll
caimans you need to Russia of eight way
that that was as effective and I brought
Mennonites the context with CBS records
and somebody said to me you know anyone
who's
Union who might know rocket all be able
to sing in English in dual record here
that's against matter of fact I am
president letting rather could do that
thing was Boris revenge drop so we
signed boring prevention thought for the
first question record contract in the
mid-80s and of course where you have to
come here to cut the record and of
course he slept on my floor of course
all my graduate students loved this
especially the girls and we said
Professor Sanders and you agree dementia
come to play at the Christmas party at
the Harriman Institute that's it sure
but no problem 1240 be glad to do so
Brett Lawrie up and he's playing and an
evidence senior political scientists who
had a MacArthur Genius prize came up to
me and say Sanders which rink is dirty
hippie here for this is the guy who is
advising president you knighted States
so it's not just journalists or ignorant
Marvin Cal started in the mid 50's it
was a CBS correspondent was one of the
last Murrow boys did a smart thing to
prepare to go to Russia he went to
Harvard and studied with Marshall for
Marvin event rushbig Marvin wanted to
show more than high politics what was
going on in the Kremlin and more than
Moscow this was very hard to do in the
mid-60s spent a year planning a trip
down the border control his gospel radio
minder wouldn't let him out of sight
they went to a worker's house worker was
not even step out of my butt
does everyone look like you yes everyone
looks like you by the way my the stellar
radio monitor from the mid-80s networks
as an information officer let's Embassy
in Moscow good training
Marvin did this hour a servant
commentary beautiful footage of the
Volga visually stunning intellectually
making up that revealing but it showed a
good deal of the countryside in Russia
we never got to see that we didn't get
to hear about what he says in January
Rose is it still inconclusive is the
economic struggle still inconclusive I
called Marvin I said hey Marvin I'm
going to I'm going to quote you you
think do you mind I don't want to take
you out of context I think taking people
out of context all right my job always
is to call them up I happen to have the
great fortune of going to em get you
with with little guide our remember the
lights that guide our was here and he
and I managed to get into a fight the
fight goes back years and I call them up
on the phone and I say listen you little
fat farm I'm going to say this on
national TV about you what do you say it
can help that since much of colleges
mentor and was my friend it's all about
friends it's how you get to know this
we put down the excess the journalists
had two Soviet officials Daniel Schorr
said he had more access to crucial after
he did this interview then he had in the
eight years that he was covering that
great Democrat former president Columbia
University 20 david ives power much
better person now finally we did two
hours primetime TV this german kid
Mateos roost landed in his plane it's
all about timing can you imagine can you
imagine doing two hours on national
television about Russia now nothing
devoted to it we don't care if we care
nights the other job I want the Cold War
to come back please come back it was
very good for business we're going to do
two hours significant resources 1987 and
all my bosses and you should never
listen to your bosses at CBS said can
you consume interview with garbage truck
can you get us in an interview with
Gorbachev can you get us into Buick
orbiter can you get us in interview
Gorbachev now garbage trucks a really
interesting guy although can't do an
interview with them because
does is talk I mean he'll tell you what
corporate Trump says and they don't tell
you what Gorby Trump thinks about what
Gorby Trump says then otel occasionally
he'll tell you about Steve cover and you
know that's a great thing so I suggested
her ethically to them I said there's
someone you haven't heard up you've
never heard his name's Forrest nickel
ions yells I think he's becoming god I
think he make a more interesting
interview I think he'd make great
television they said hello Sanders
you're out of your mind out his spell
back Yeltsin give ye y ooh wow & chris
boyce had never done a national
interview not on Russian TV not on
Soviet TV not in America TV and we had
to follow him around to prove to him
that we weren't wolves that what
Vysotsky said wolves who's the wolf
who's the hunter when we convinced him
and eventually Yeltsin one of the
reasons he got chucked out of being
party secretary for Moscow was building
a cult of personality with foreign
correspondents and in these days if you
got thrown out of the Central Committee
you got thrown out of the Presidium you
got thrown out of the poll apart there
was no coming back why did you go to war
on a cement factory in Mongolia sand
that what happened to Molotov I kept
going to see Yeltsin I kept going I kept
taking my friends I've made friends with
his helpers his cadre from ecat and
guess what when events started happening
with an election to be President or a
coup something like that his assistants
Nina Joseph nut Tanya they remembered
who was nice to them in
at times and guess who had great sources
did I know this but this is how it's
going to work out no why did I do this
because I trusted my intuition I trusted
learning from the poet's like to Jeff
the good correspondent reporting from
Russia internalizes the to check Maxim
he or she and many of our best ones of
been she's as Jill been as Jill spoken
yet there's one of the best bets one of
the best he or she learns this what you
can't explain and uses it in dealing
with people to make pictures that tell
the stories in a cold war two Americans
so that Americans have pictures in their
heads of people like that and when they
throw people like this out of power this
is the date he lost power Arjun Barbic
killed under mysterious circumstances my
cameraman Yuri died because the health
care system still stinks in Russia and
he couldn't get health care because some
of the economic changes brought on by
people who are advisors in pain
went with Christine hands like that
bloody-handed criminal Jeffrey Sachs
things change people change its people
in pictures in your minds that are how
we remember what went on Cold War what
Cold War the one that started in 1811
the one that's started in 1917 the one
that started in Yalta the one that
started with the disruption of Chechnya
under Yeltsin or maybe under Putin is
there a cold war now yeah it's a cold
war against the people of Russia carried
on by the people in the Kremlin Thank
you Thank You Jonathan as always I have
to get at Tommen Rose you better come
back up here as always I have to say
that I'm gonna ask two questions and the
first one I prepare before your remarks
the second one I should have prepared
before we remarks but I forgot about it
one the first one is is about the fact
that everybody on this panel well the
three journalists here I don't count
myself um either teaches now or is
considering teaching and has very close
ties with academia I from the other on
the other hand was someone who at the
time when it was rare was well first a
graduate student studying contemporary
Soviet literature and culture and then
in 1987 moved from being a graduate
student right in the middle of things to
being a faculty member at this
university I just don't want to look at
Gorbachev you don't know he corporate
what happened to the vysotsky i thought
we're gonna have more music
slutsky before you came in but might put
him back you put him back on anyway but
I'm really sorry I missed that christmas
party by the way I missed that Christmas
party I dunno I don't know how I'd
manage to do that then but but anyway um
and um you know I on the one hand I mean
I am incredibly grateful for the books
by American correspondence and his
maverick I have to say that you know we
had hoped to include also we wanted even
bigger discussion open that wouldn't
have been able to hear as much from you
but he'd Rick Smith and Bob Kaiser are
both on deadline finishing their books
that are doing the week that'll remind
some of your of 1974 when they were both
ready you know racing to get books out
which I used in my teaching and I you
know I want to say that I was always
very grateful for coverage because if
you were trying to teach contemporary
Soviet culture you needed journalism and
and even with the collapse of the Soviet
Union when we started the course that
Herman students have to take the
legacies course scholarship couldn't
keep up I mean we needed to go to news
articles and still continue need to go
to news articles on the other hand as
someone again and you know needing to
get tenure and starting in 1987 and
working on popular culture and Writers
Union disintegration and acai and
institutional disintegration along with
literature I found myself perilously
close to doing things that academia
considered journalism and which well
which is a dirty word right well if it
was tricky you know if you published in
the right places you could get all you
know you could get away with it but I
mean there has been this this
interesting and I think very complicated
synergy between between academia and and
the press where Russia is concerned I
don't know whether it's different I do i
would say for instance i do think that
there is less of a tendency to come to
experts now in academia than there was
once on the part of the press
I I think they're on the other hand
maybe less reluctance to use press
sources because there's a growing
interest now by the way Russian
enrollments are really healthy here I
just want everybody now you've been
hearing a lot of things about no
interest at this particular institution
there's a there's a lot of interest does
that mean that the administration can
make good on their promises to the
Harriman's and and you have more faculty
um where were we doing we can Jonathan
feel like I came in in the middle of
something okay yes it's gone betrayal
but but Jonathan we're on another panel
so anyway I'm so I guess what I'm asking
you is to comment you know as you answer
each other if you'd like to if you would
address that the other issue was a there
was another correspondent I would have
loved to have had here today but he's
really been out of the mix but Rose
knows oh my t-ball of you have no number
one point or another and that's John
Cohen who was the time magazine bureau
chief during almost a decade of the
glass loss since 1995 he's no longer a
journalist you know but I remembered he
did he was invited me to a conference on
journalists covering Russia at Harvard
roughly around 86 or 87 and then and he
was the only person in the room who had
a master's in Russian studies from
Columbia and every other person I'd gone
to journalism school and there was a big
discussion about how do you better
prepare to be a journalist to covering
Russia by being a regional specialist or
by going to journalism school of course
the vast majority of people in the room
said by going to journalism school you
know so I think you know Jonathan opened
that can of worms so I think that that
might you know you know all of you of
more than paid your dues and learning
about Russia in one way or another you
know and I Jay still pain you know many
many well that was one of the reasons
you know there are different reasons
some of you are teaching or considering
it and that's something you might also
address so i do want to leave some time
for the audience to ask questions but
perhaps if you throw up we can throw
that into the mix and then we'll go
about seven minutes over because I
how late we started so we've got about
20 minutes left in the battle okay so um
I guess I can just say a few words about
one of the good points that Kathy raised
as to her perception that the
correspondence including correspondence
covering Russia quote academics less
than they used to I think that's
probably true I'm really thought about
it but it's it is true and I think the
reason is not specifically about Russia
two countries in general the
correspondent community has begun to I
think develop the capability and a
consciousness to penetrate more deeply
into the actual people in the countries
that they cover I think corresponds have
become more skilled and I think that
they have they are finding more people
who they can easily contact a lot of
people in in Russia in many other
countries themselves are blogging are
creating user generated contact content
and so forth and come forward and are
visible and engage well with with
correspondence so it's less covering
countries as if they were you know
something in a petri dish that we're all
while peering at journalists are much
more involved in actual people and using
fewer outside sources as a whole unless
there's some specific scientific
information you need or something that's
really specialized but I can't help
saying since Associated Press is one of
the few places that really has a lot of
foreign correspondents know that might
be do you think that might be as
specialized well that's true I'm a lot
of organizations have reduced their
their foreign correspondent core course
they they look to news agencies to to
protect them on things so it's one of
the one of the things that we've had to
be able to cover wide wide variety of
things for a lot of people now that we
didn't before
jill dougherty and garrels bridget
Kendall all superior correspondents
covering Russia let's just take one
Bridget's now the diplomatic
correspondent for the BBC not exactly a
doofus job she had an undergraduate
degree at Oxford studied with Archie
Brown liberal arts education language
skills technical skills does anybody ask
you if you know how to type does anybody
ask you if you know Russian how many
Americans no foreign language anyhow
yeah the people who self-select out look
at people are going to cover China do
experts get asked I get asked a lot more
now to comment on streaming video than I
do about Russia not only people who ask
me to add to comment on Russia's when I
do a thing or I do a three-way thing
frequently at at the UN with the entire
toss bureau chief my old pal from Pravda
let America kilo and Tom Graham that's
the only time people people you know the
amount of time people spend talking
about Russia I'm glad I don't earn my
nickel talking about Russia anymore
maybe it's partly an answer the answer
is how open the country is because from
my experience editing China articles for
Business Week Business Week quotes
academic specialized specialists inside
China outside China more than they quote
academic specialists about Russia and
the other side of it that whether you
like it or don't like it that's a step
forward just look what our diplomatic
corps did in making Mike McFaul the
Ambassador that's you know that's it's
that's a step forward
why unless you would like to address one
another's comments we will open the
microphone to the audience please line
up there and please even if you spoke
yesterday we aren't a please identify
yourself and who's ever here for the FBI
would you please identify yourself for
me we should be so lucky Jonathan G do
you know that there was there was a CBS
correspondent who was a spy for the
Soviet Union named Winston Burdette and
that there was a CBS correspondent who
is a spy for the FBI named Sam Jaffe you
know when you read in the Soviet press
that some of the correspondents are
spies it's true have you ever seen the
Clark Gable nineteen forty 40 or 41
movie comrade X where comrade X is a
correspondent in Moscow who is a spy and
the movie begins with Clark Gable and as
an inimitable fashion saying face it
baby there ain't no news in Moscow
I'm documenting founder of cinema
in here
entertain
thank you
I would like to make some comments first
of all
great friends in Russia kill you make
such great friends at Columbia I love
Kenneth age he is here speaking today
I'm here Jeffrey Sachs should be chained
to a tree in Siberia and it's nothing I
haven't said to his face excuse me I is
my comment about showed up into to
reject every cent although it does have
lots of different what's close to
Siberia doing promotion farming's where
I have worked I was this like to point
out that I totally agree with workout
pictures and a thousand words since I'm
a talking to be filled so now by Jack
not logical friend and the academics are
basically not interested in which is
very unfortunate for students absolutely
others and my thesis is the reasons that
academics
is that their push the covers all the
time what parish and since they can't
make films they can no attention to them
which is truly tragic okay my other
point is my next film is going to being
a bad thing under Russia okay the
Russian that nobody talks about
recruiting cycling there are worth okay
which should be discussed because that
is basic Russia now that's a really
tough form and how do you get that
across to the American public so my
question is adamant ordered every other
Russia and I gave a terrific idea
yesterday which nobody on the panel
picked up because when I was last in
Russia I saw something that was truly
example and I booth at the padded toilet
at this penalty
okay everybody knows what they want
which is arriving in Russia they are
truly horrible and I get it Columbus
want to die
however one I was in one of these
backwater towns this is all gone it was
completely inhabited by or fitness and
these orphans were working and what were
they working at they had a purpose for
internet cafe which is how I found their
internet cafe was in his old broken-down
born that they Septon and they had books
that they were actually make me running
with and they were making money because
they knew how to work at computers and
they will be coming forward as major
members of the particular town these are
orphans and really discarded when we
come from
one hand they were told you Carrie in
addition to which some Americans had
donated these communities so they were
real all of computers and other that's a
high tax deduction honor but the only
computers work in their favor interested
charge by the minute and so you had
there's a lot of minutes and I infinity
tolerance which was making an epson
clean was was heralded so I'm spent I
asked yesterday instead does anybody
heard of this quick example certain
things in here those weapons and handles
criminals it handles education
empowerment I want to know as anybody
else for this anyplace I think you bring
up it along has anybody picked up on
your side you and why do you think of
the idea that's my question and I hope
there are other people in his wedding
that pick up on this idea how to empower
orphans and reduce the poverty and they
lived in this broken-down shed and they
loved it thankfully I'm Sasha why don't
you come and gasp because we have we
have and I see nagi getting up maybe you
want to take let's take a few questions
together and and uh so in this my name
is Sasha do well on the Harriman's
student so I think at this conference
people have sort of lamented the demise
of the old style of Russian coverage of
Correspondence spending a lot of time
there and as mr. cendars was saying
really get to know everyone that's you
know make all those connections and
friends with people but that's sort of
changed now and it seems like Beth noble
yesterday talked about how many bureaus
have closed down I would speculate that
it's unlikely that that trend would
really reverse itself so what do you see
happening going forward if those kinds
of relationships aren't possible and if
there's more of a parachute style of
journalism where do we go from there
good morning carnage gahanna from russia
russian union of journalists and partly
Moscow State University I am really
appreciated for this session I think
it's one of the best joint master
classes of international reporting and
journalism as and should be as i heard
recently in 1020 several years and i
wish we could opportunity to show some
fragments of probably the whole tape of
it for young journalists here and there
and probably it would be really exciting
to arrange a joint russian-american
summer school or some small seminar and
i wish it took place in Russia is really
important because for Russian journalist
is important to know this by your
position and to understand that it's
important to be very deeply involved in
culture of country you cover just try to
cover up lento deal with and some other
journalists stuff because journalism is
challenged everywhere and my question is
now to probably roles first about
economy did you cover corruption in
Russian American business and do you
think that corruption could make any
obstacles for future Russian American
business programs that what it's about
coverage of this issue in the United
States I I admiring your figures I hope
you'll get some similar figures about
the United States and probably results
will be similar but i hope you will have
those figures about representation of
the united states in russian media which
is not enough definitely and i think
also it would be very important to ask
ourselves and our members of mcfall and
sort of commission of new stage of
russian partnership the plane songs and
devoted to real exchange between
fessional think I'll think we'll make
this the last question yes professor
Kent what happened to these please
identify yourself I've hairs these
post-coup shift independent and
professional journalists and then you
know the media became so anemic in
Russia so what happened to these
professional journalists you know in the
post Khrushchev period the second
question is so they seem to be a bit of
a contradiction here and I didn't quite
understand is oh where did the
government get information if the if the
media was so anemic during the Soviet
times I mean there has to be feedback
that information has to come to the
government from the media I mean and yet
it seems like the government was giving
the press the information you know I
couldn't quite understand that thank you
can I slip I see one more person I want
to slip in here identify yourself I'm
Susan human and I'm an academic who went
into helicopter journalism and worked
for NBC and I would think that the
question right now between the
importance of academics and helicopter
journalism are just sending people in on
short stints is interesting but probably
less important because so many people
are working there and they're actually
living there so you have students that
go there and do research and they might
be important but I don't know how you
see that but i have to say that the
helicopter journalism i did was the most
exciting thing in my academic background
was minimally important my linguistic
abilities were important but the
connections I had were really what what
mattered but i'd be interested in your
response to how we hope that coverage of
other parts of the world and not just
the insides of our Republican candidates
becomes part of our lives again and
we're wondering how how we can revive
this and how you see the revival coming
well I think that it's always a little
dangerous to to set up with an agenda in
journalism at least it leads to bad
things and that is why we we don't set
out to say well this year we we shall
you know right certain stories or take
certain approaches or and and and i
think the the russia story is going to
be a function of russia as much as of
anything else rather than the decision
made you know by news organizations /
say that we you know we shall increase
coverage of russia it will depend on
events and if if the story becomes the
kind of story you know economically
politically in the streets that are
culturally that begins to attract more
attention and that in itself becomes
becomes more important and more visible
than I think coverage will follow I
think that you know when when when
russian movies become more popular in
the United States when when when when
Russia begins creating products that
everyone buys in the United States when
when when political developments in
Russia when candidate here says gee you
know they got a good idea in Russia they
do this and this we should try that then
you know interest will grow organically
it's not saying that we will set out to
to to promote just as a as a goal in
itself and just respond to a couple
things that that that other people
raised I think the the I didn't mean to
over glamorize the the professionalism
of journalism under crew chef it was it
was more structured journalists were
better trained and they had a better
sense that they were carrying out their
official mission did not mean they all
turned into Woodward and Bernstein and
were you know tearing the Kremlin apart
that never happened and and and and it's
it's something that that is only only a
thought now for for some journalists
even today and the last the last
question died
respond to was how the government got
information is an excellent question
since they couldn't get it out of the
press and they were writing the press I
think there were the main source of
information was probably letters that
that people wrote to newspapers for some
incredible reason to was Oviatt citizens
used to write hundreds of thousands of
letters to newspapers then if we got
printed I don't know why they did but it
was considered a place to to write and
complain and i think that the that there
was a lot of that information was
gathered up and consolidated by by state
security bodies and political bodies and
and did get to the top to some degree
but even that went through a choking
process that i think it was one of the
one of the biggest problems for the
whole Soviet regime that there was a
tendency to report good news up not bad
news so I think a lot of the discontent
just just never got to the attention of
the leadership or they never took it
that seriously uh what you want to go
Jennifer okay to respond to the question
about corruption during my own period in
the Soviet Union and Russia the pace of
the political economic story was so fast
and there was only me and one other
sometimes correspondent that we didn't
get to do long investigative stories we
mainly wrote about during my time
corruption is part of the business
climate and you know the idea that
people had to pay protection money and
that kind of thing as time went on
especially in the 1990s later on in in
business weeks experience there was a
little bit more there were a few more
investigative stories but that has never
to be honest that has never been
Businessweek strength I think some other
publications have done a much better job
writing about publication corruption but
I think that's a very important issue
and it's more and more important as time
goes on to respond to the question of
parachute journalism and how do you
cover the world and all of that
even though the number of bureaus have
decreased in Moscow as Beth pointed out
yesterday certain certain bureaus have
increased and I don't work for Bloomberg
Businessweek anymore but Bloomberg has
the largest Bureau in Moscow right now
foreign Bureau American Bureau anyways
in Moscow with about 20 people and they
cover various aspects of the economy
some of it very straight forward every
once in a while they do a big
investigative piece on on corruption and
also there's this organization which may
be the journalists in the room know
about called Global post which hires not
extremely well paid journalists on the
ground but they do they do help fill the
gaps for for publications that have
shrunk their foreign bureaus and in fact
business week before it was bought by
Bloomberg used Global post after we
closed our own Bureau in 2005 corruption
Jonathan I am going to point out that
the next panel is scheduled to start in
five minutes so I'm corruption in one
minute one minute don't with corruption
all the time the nice man who was
simultaneously oh hi Colette the nice
man who was simultaneously working at
the Kremlin and setting up video
international which had a monopoly on
commercials on television wanted me to
come join him I said to him you know I'm
working for CBS news that we've got
ethics he said I'll never mind that
you'll make a lot of money video
international still is making a lot of
money I am NOT and I am stupid
television we didn't do a lot of stories
Khodorkovsky didn't want me to come work
for him and I'm glad that to chief
taught me to say no
I think Frank Perrin marriage yeah I got
another minute for parachute journalism
this in Susan's questions a very good
one I'm now doing a three-hour
documentary for PBS god help me PBS it
you know you only can watch it if you
have a PhD or drive a Volvo and they pay
very little so my university is
subsidizing the cost of my journalism
I'm using a lot of cameraman and young
people some just graduated from Moscow
State University to do some of the foot
work we're doing an hour on skull cava
and two hours on cybernetics in Russia
the parachute journalism question is a
very interesting one because we do have
this breadth of knowledge and experience
now and with the lack of Giroud's it is
easy to drop in and find someone who has
been trained by let's say inter news and
work with them to go and do a story very
quickly and very very well the other
part is with the advent of streaming
video on the internet documentaries are
coming in a new form to new audiences
and one of the places that needs to be
supporting investigative work our places
with greater financial resources
financial lucidity it's a nice work
including universities so have some of
your graduate students do videos and
documentaries for their Harmon Institute
certificate essays instead of these
little pieces of paper that nobody ever
reads like mine that's still sitting on
the shelf downstairs thank you very much
and thank you all for being thank